you know you've had uh so many
surprising friendships i mean with you
first of all surprising friendships
you've made friends with so many huge
stars over the years
and i many people marveled at your
friendship with don rickles because he
was publicly
so different his act was so different
than you and his persona was so
different than you
but you've also known uh frank sinatra
for example
you you were good friends with frank is
that true yeah
jenny and i we we uh we we had a beach
house at the frank had a beach house and
uh
we would be invited to their house and
that was not that was a great honor
because he was
he was a giant you know he was a very
engineer
he was very philanthropic
and they tell the story about
he was going to do the tonight show with
johnny carson
and he was getting a shoe shot and the
guy shined his shoes they're
ready to go in to do uh so frank said uh
he said to the guy who trying to choose
he said
what's what's the biggest tip you ever
got
and the guy said uh a hundred dollars mr
sinatra
and frank pulled off two big ones he
said
yeah now that 200. that's that's the
biggest tip you ever got
he said thank you very much mr sinatra
he said who gave you the hundred dollars
just
out of curiosity he said you did mr snot
that's a true story that's good
the ohio story i may i made up for you
yeah the
alien civilization that's uh six weeks
ahead you made up
but the sinatra story yeah is true